[Music]
[Applause]
drex here from drexfactor poi sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
today i'm going to teach you how to
dance like me and break down a combo
that went viral on instagram last month
should be a lot of fun before we dive in
though i do want to give a quick shout
out to the friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel johnny howard les
muchinski and becca beckham thank you
all so very much for your support from
my work and my mission so this is a
combo that pulls in some elements from
outside of the poi spinning world
number one there's a lot of locking in
it this is a hip-hop dance style and
number two there's a lot of shotguns in
it shotguns are a particular type of
glow stringing technique wherein you
wrap up the poi around your hand to
immobilize it this gives us the
opportunity to do some pretty cool
suspensions and that is definitely on
display in this particular combo so i'm
going to show you how to put together
all these different pieces into
something that i think looks
particularly eye-catching and i hope
that you do too if you're new here i
make tons of videos about poi i teach
tricks i teach technique and in cases
like this i teach people how to move
with their poi too so please give me a
subscribe if you haven't already now for
this combo you're going to need quite a
few tricks under your belt here's the
full list first up you're going to need
some basic anti-grids such as extension
versus static spin as well as static
spin versus triquetra
next you're going to need to know how to
do split time opposites anti-spin
flowers
and finally how to do zan's diamond in
split time opposites as well
i will leave links to tutorials for all
these tricks down in the description if
you need to catch up or at the card that
just popped up if you're watching on
youtube i'm going to show you the combo
at full speed then break it down for you
piece by piece before finally reviewing
it in slow motion once again
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so first up we have to talk a
little bit about something called a
shotgun this is a glow stringing
technique that involves wrapping the
prop completely around your hand until
you immobilize it now i have a very
particular length of tether and
thickness of it such that as i'm
wrapping my tether around my hand i get
like two coils of it and then i get to a
point where uh there's so little of the
tether left that i essentially wind up
in a position where uh the head is kind
of immobilized like if i wiggle my hand
around that head's not going anywhere as
opposed to say like if i left one coil
out and i wiggle it around that poi is
still moving so what you're gonna have
to do a little bit of groundwork here to
find out exactly what is the right
amount of coiling to work for a shotgun
for you to immobilize the poi
because it is going to be important to
this combo now unlike my usual director
for doing these combos there's very
little leg work in this that is
partially deliberate and partially not
but it works pretty well in this context
because i gave you something really
dancey last week so i'm going to give
you something that is a little bit more
riveted in place which is is probably a
better fit for the vertical video
formats of tick tock and instagram
anyway here's how it starts you want to
start from the shotgun you want to have
those poi wrapped up in your hands you
want
your left hand on top and your right
hand down below that left hand should be
about even with your shoulders the right
hand should be even with your hips now
you're going to start over here to your
left hand side and you're going to pivot
your entire body over to the right
you're going to do this
by locking now
locking is a dance technique wherein
every time you move a thing
you're basically
dime stopping wherever you're arriving
at and you're giving yourself kind of a
rebound to really make it like hit for
the audience that boom you've just made
that move right so we get we we
we lock from left
boom to right and then we drop out one
coil
try and make sure to keep the alignment
of your hands even as you're doing this
uh it breaks the effect a little bit if
uh
if they say like it'll wonky like this
now you let out the other coil again try
to keep the poi aligned it's very very
important
now from here we're going to make a
quick switch between two anti-grids
namely
i'm going to go ahead and swing around
in extension versus static spin here but
i'm also going to halt over on my left
side here to switch back
and what this does is it switches the
direction of the static spin so it's no
longer
we started off with it going
counterclockwise but when we make this
switch we're just we're doing a pendulum
with it and we're switching it around to
going
uh counterclockwise excuse me so we
start going clockwise boom we switch to
counterclockwise now the right hand poi
does not switch which direction it's
going so this takes us into an anti-spin
namely static spin versus triquetra
now we're only going to do one rep of
each of these antibrids so as we move
over to the right stage right here we
drop one coil we drop two coils we
switch into that anti-big going one way
we switch into it the other way and we
get out of it by having our right hand
execute a shotgun across the bottom of
that anti-bridge how exactly does that
happen basically you're doing the two
coils of the shotgun as the poi is going
from one side to the other here
the bottom of the triquetra is two
downbeats so as soon as your hand kind
of hits the bottom corner of that
triquetra you're already starting the
wrap there right here is where it starts
and it ends over on the right hand side
yeah so we do that shotgun and when the
shotgun happens i want to see a reaction
to it in your body it's not just that we
do the shotgun and we kind of hang out
here it's that going into the shotgun
boom has an effect on our body uh see
how i'm doing that locking technique
again there was like
boom taking me over to the side here
really really really try and make sure
that that boom lands for you and now we
get to have a little bit of fun now i
will be the first to confess that i do
not actually have a full plan as to
what's going on here this section is
what i would refer to as structured
improv basically what you're going to do
is you're going to push back once twice
and on the third time your right hand is
going to start spinning around with your
left hand now you can literally do
anything with this left hand poi that
you want to and your right hand is going
to follow it all the way around it's
basically just a riff on the idea of
what an antibrid even is it's a moment
where one hand has a relationship with
the other poi head and literally i do
not care what tricks you're using in
here it could just be random
improvisation just so long as
the hand is even with the poi head but
it it's exploring the space with the two
for a little while it does have an end
though and that end happens boom when we
stall the left hand pulley over to the
right and then we're gonna install it
again over to the left so just to review
we have our triquetra versus static boom
we push back and go into our structured
improv and we stall
stall before moving on to the next bit
all right so from here we're going to
get our right hand out of this
arrangement where it's following the
left namely we're going to take it up
and around back the way it came part of
the reason we're going to do this is it
gives us an opportunity to finally
unwrap that poi so as you go over you're
going to start spinning the poi
counterclockwise and that takes you
around into something like an anti-spin
flower when you arrive back over to your
left hand side that activates the right
hand and boom the two hands go around in
split time opposites anti-spin together
now you're gonna get all the way around
and you're going to switch this into
zan's diamond going split time opposites
you're going to do that twice you're
going to stall out out to your right
hand side and as the two poi drop down
around
you do one last shotgun and you finish
with your body all crossed up like this
your right hand reaching over to the
left your left hand reaching behind you
this shape is important to hit so that
last section of it is we take the right
hand out and around and boom into split
ops it's anti-spin
zan's diamond
going across going across and boom come
out of it into shotguns and pose
loose steel yeah so the whole thing then
from the top we start over here on stage
left we swivel over to the right we drop
one coil we drop two coils switch into
our anti-grid take it back around and
boom into our shotgun push push switch
into
having that poi
follow the other one around we stall
stall bring the poi on out split
opposites anti-spin zan's diamond
and
we come out of it
boom to drop into
blue steel
heck yeah let's see that again in slo-mo
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
cool so when it comes right down to it
there's not actually that many tricks
going on here but it still looks pretty
red i think
if you go ahead and learn this combo
please do me a favor and if you post
video of yourself please tag me i am
drexfactor on both instagram and youtube
and i would love to come check out your
hard work
[Music]
if you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
the video and of course to help my
channel grow this video would not have
been possible without the amazing
support of these awesome people right
here these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they along with the people
listed down in the description helped
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible do you like these
videos do you want to send or support me
if you're not already you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up
there you can get access to some awesome
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission to try and
bring poi spinning and flow arts to the
wider world and help people connect with
their brains and their bodies as
creative individuals so do go check that
out please and thank you if you dug this
combo and you'd like to learn more like
it i will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of other videos just like this
one down in the description or up on
screen here if you are watching this
video on youtube the youtube algorithm
also thinks that you'll really like this
video on top so that also might be worth
checking out if you haven't already
please subscribe and above all make sure
that you get out and flow today it's
good for your brain and it's good for
your body and i will see you with a
brand new video on monday thanks so much
for watching
peace